hey what up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 27 of game
programming so today we're going to take
a look at actually creating a tile so
yesterday we do a little bit creating
the tile class kind of like we did with
the level class right it's like a
template it's like a little thing to
actually you know extend upon to create
subclasses of this class to actually
deal with specific things so it's like I
don't know I don't know how it's like
the top lit hierarchy really and yeah
and so we did that and then the next
episode after we created the level class
we sort of dilled dealt with the random
level class which extends level and is
basically just using the code here to
actually create something that we can
actually use similar thing today right
we've created this tile thing yesterday
and now we're actually going to apply
that and create a grass title object so
over here out in our tile folder we'll
just right-click hit new and hit class
and we'll type grass oops
grass tile and that's it and what grass
style will be again is it will extend
it'll extend our tile class if we type
extends tile I'll extend it now similar
to our last time we actually have we
don't have a default constructor our
constructor actually has a sprite in
here so let's just simply add the
constructor in here and this constructor
is actually perfect for us because what
it does again is when a new grass or
grass how objective created it dot it
executes the code that is in here which
just simply sets the public sprite
object true to this sprite object that's
in the parameter and again it just it
inputs from here so in other words when
we actually create a grass tile object
um you know will will will apply the
right sprite that's in here so when we
do actually inner instantiate it for the
for the first time and and last time
again because it will only when they do
it once um and AH son you'll see what I
mean without in a minute then we will
have to specify sprite so now that we've
done that there's one more thing that we
actually need to put into our graph
style class now if we go back into
class we basically just got three
methods right one one of them is
actually constructed but we've got two
main methods right we've got the render
and the solid now grass is not solid in
other words we can walk through grass or
through the grass tile because of grass
tiles like really take part of the map
it's the background which doesn't have
any collision applied to it and because
of that my microphone is getting like
friggin hang on let me just adjust that
ah sorry about that I'm I've heard that
um anyway it's getting like it's like
sinking and I was going on anyway um so
the grasses and solid grass isn't
collidable we actually just walk on top
of grass we don't want to bump into it
and actually you know for supply to stop
which is why we don't actually have to
add a you know we don't actually have to
override this this method because by
default you know we've set a solid to
return fall so in other words this won't
have collision by default so if you
create tiles that do not have collision
you actually don't you know you don't
have to um you don't have to doing this
would be completely pointless is what
I'm saying if we if we can if we copy
this and paste into here you'll see that
we are overriding it but we're
overriding it with the exact same thing
so it's just it's redundant whereas if
it was collidable and we put something
like true here again it's not redundant
anymore because we actually change the
value of it but grass is actually non
non solid it's not collidable so by
default we'll keep it as false the other
method is the actual render method that
of course needs to be in every single
tile thing because we need it to render
so we'll simply copy and paste it here
you'll see that it overrides it which is
beautiful
again we're asked to have anything to
put into this method yet this is where
we'll actually I'll just add a quick
comment you can do that by hitting
double for slash I'm sure everyone knows
that's how you create a comment so in
other words this code the the anything
following these two these two false
lashes will not be counted as code it
won't be it won't be compiled um it's
just a comment I do render stuff here so
this is this is where will actually
render once we actually make the correct
method in the screen class which will
probably do next uh next time so
tomorrow but yeah this is this is where
we'll actually render everything so that
all set that's pretty much it now all we
need to do is actually create the grass
tile object so we've created class now
we need to actually you know create an
object that we can use out of it because
Java is an object-oriented programming
language so we'll just type and this is
similar to the thing that we didn't
sprite where we just want public Spanish
public static sprite for articles news
right over here you'll see as well that
will actually this estatic will actually
memorize that it's called grass because
that is a sprite that were actually
going to use for our grass tile class or
our grass tile tile really so public
static sprite oh sorry not sprite public
static tile and we'll just call it grass
right equals new grass tile now notice
how I'm actually setting it equal to
grass style not to tile so in sprite we
didn't have any subclasses so when we
created a new sprite we just set it
equal to new sprite it's the same object
but here we're dealing with different
objects I saw over here we're dealing
with different objects we've got tile
and we got grass tile you guys might be
like you know how can you set tile equal
to a different class and that is
obviously because grass tile actually
extends tile so in other words grass
tile is really it's part of the tile
object think of it of that as that way
grass tile is the same as tile it's the
same type of style same as like five is
an integer as well as nine is an integer
or eight is an integer but same thing
here you know tile and grass tile
they're both tiles so we can set them
equal to each other
new grass tile and again the parameter
that we created here is a sprite so
we'll simply type a sprite dot grass and
that is it
if we save then you said you should say
that there are no errors so again what
we've done here is we've created a
static object of a tile called grass
again it's static because will will
never will never ever be creating any
more grass objects there's only one it's
it's it's static the grass tile is
static it does not change it always has
the same parameters it can't suddenly
become solid or anything it's it's it's
static it's constant and we've set it
equal to a new grass tile with you know
sprite or grass so in other words what
we've done
we've created a new tile object but
we've set it equal to this new set of
rules and parameters that we've created
in the grass tile object because if we
just set this equal to for example new
tile right that'll work that'll be fine
and that will in this case actually work
perfectly but the problem is that if we
want to add other things into here like
for example here we do really need to
render it what we can do is instead of
having all the all of our code in this
one class and then being a better being
in and then when we'd have to say you
know we have to probably more parameters
into here so if it's solid or not we
have to create different instances of
this tile class for if it's solid or not
for example all that the way that it has
to render stuff like that that'd be
that'd just be all over the place but
here we can actually set it equal to a
specific set of rules that we actually
create in a subclass and they of course
will be applied to this template class
so that's how that works I hope you guys
understand how that works it's not easy
to explain but um once it once you
actually get the hang of it you'll see
you'll see what things you can and can't
do with this and hopefully you know
it'll be it'll be sweet so yeah that's
going to that's going to conclude
today's episode of game programming um
if you liked it please hit the like
button and what more I guess I'll see
you guys tomorrow
one other thing is yet tomorrow will
probably cover going back into our
screen class and actually you know
modifying this random method to actually
render our tiles onto the screen so yes
in sort of see how that works and and we
can we can finally fill this in
so yeah until then guys goodbye
you